my guest tonight is an academy
award-winning actor who has starred in
such films as the deer hunter pulp
fiction
true romance just to name a very few his
latest movie
wild mountain time is available on
demand it's a beautiful film
please welcome the great christopher
walken sir how are you
thank you it's good to see you yeah i
want to say i want to start off by
saying
if there's one thing i notice in this
business for my entire life
it's who's got the best hair and i
maintain
that you have in my opinion maybe
the best hair of anyone in the acting
business
what's your secret what do you do i
still have hair
and i don't know all my life people have
talked about my hair
and i don't know why well it's fantastic
i mean
we're on zoom but if we weren't on zoom
i would reach over and i would try to
put my hand
into your hair that's how good it is and
you would probably
you would stop me i'm sure but uh it's
it's
thick it's got life and it's distinctive
it's just regular hair and it doesn't
seem like much to me
you're wrong you're totally wrong my
whole life is about hair
you've got hair i don't know i've got
hair what is your secret for
do you do anything to your hair is there
any secrets you have use special oils
creams bombs no years ago when i was a
kid
a friend of mine anthony perkins the
actor he said that if you grab your hair
every morning for five minutes and
tug on it chances are you won't
lose it because apparently keeping your
hair has a lot to do with keeping the
blood flowing
in your scalp so i've done that so when
you wake up in the morning you grab your
hair
and you pull on it as hard as you can
for five minutes i watch the news and i
pull on my hair yeah
that would come naturally these days
yeah
you know help me clear something up
because i heard a rumor
that you auditioned for the role of han
solo
and if is that true first of all
yes but you know at that time i think
you know hundreds of actors auditioned
for that part
i also auditioned for love story you
know again it must have
been hundreds of people you auditioned
for the ryan o'neil part in love story
yes i auditioned for superman and and so
did
everybody else so i didn't get the part
and it's a good thing because i wouldn't
have been much good
well i did i beg to disagree i'm now
rethinking all of those roles
with you in them and i i think you as
han solo would have been fantastic
no slight on harrison ford i think he
did a fine job
but i would have loved your would it be
very different han solo
very different but too much maybe like
chewbacca
still you know
[Music]
you would have just done a lot of you
think maybe
too much too much i was thinking about
this today in preparation for our
interview
you have had so many iconic roles
so many great performances yet
one of the things that probably
uh you might be best known for
or among your best known performances
would be in the sign out live sketch
cowbell have you found that to be true
yes it was a very good sketch and and uh
but i i don't understand why why it
follows me around like it does
and how does it follow you around give
us an example
oh you know i i it doesn't i was in a
restaurant in singapore
and the couple at the next table at one
point the guy said to me uh chris you
know this salad needs more cowbell
[Laughter]
and i thought i've i've it's gone too
far
you're in singapore you're in singapore
and it follows you yes
that says and uh i don't know why that
sketch became so famous
it's mysterious you know how some things
catch on
yes it is mysterious i think it has
something to do with your
voice in the way you said cowbell i
really believe if anyone else had done
that role
it would not that sketch would not have
endured the way it does
i give you credit for that it's a fine
sketch but i think it's the way you said
cowbell
well it was also it was will ferrell and
you know what is it to
meet the reaper or
something about the reaper oh yes uh uh
don't fear the reaper don't fear the
reaper
yeah yeah will you know yes i'm sure all
those were all great elements but i
think you pulled it all together
well thanks but it's it's uh
kind of run its course no it hasn't
it's gonna keep going
no matter what else you achieve in your
career it will keep going and there's
nothing we can do about it
um i know that i'm very appreciative
that you could do this interview
because we are on opposite ends of the
united states
and i also don't take it for granted
because i know that you are not a
tech savvy person you are not
comfortable with technology is that true
absolutely somebody had to set this all
up for me i
i don't have a cell phone you wanna have
a cell phone
no i don't have a computer i've never
sent a text or an email
or how do you make
a phone call let's say you're on a movie
set and you want to
make a phone call to say to me to your
old friend conan o'brien how would you
do it
well here at home i have a land mine a
land line
i hope you don't have a land mine let's
open it
that was here when i when i when i moved
in
uh same number and uh when i on a set
sometimes they give me a cell phone but
it's not for me it's so they can
reach me that's amazing i'm i think so
many of us have become so dependent on
ours i'm fascinated by the idea that you
don't have
uh access even to a computer do you ever
have you ever googled yourself on a
computer
i have not uh my wife has has
uh a computer and she knows about these
things and uh
you know that pretty much takes care of
it for me
it's your wife funny we'll tell you
you know what they're saying about you
on the internet if you needed to even
know that
she says don't look
[Laughter]
do you um have you ever looked at uh
google earth that's something that i'm
not very
tech savvy but i love google earth
sometimes i like to go on and just look
at my
where i live just to see you ever done
that yes you know in the old days
on movie sets actors would sit around
between setups and takes and they would
play
cards or they'd read a book and now of
course they all have their cell phones
and i said to a friend of mine could you
google my house and it was really
amazing i could see
you know lawn chairs and the car in the
driveway it's really
fantastic you know i hope it was your
car
yeah that's what they say watch out for
those uh strange cars
yeah uh uh so that's i'm glad that you
have some familiarity with it
if you're not getting if you're not on
the internet do you get
mail then let's say fans want to write
you letters they want to write to
the great christopher walken they want
to write do you get fan mail like
through the u.s postal system
yes what kind of stuff do you do you
read those letters you read any of them
i do and uh it's
it's uh that that's a tricky thing
because
you have to be careful about
acknowledging sometimes i get
uh strange uh things
not too strange but just odd and uh
of course you know if you answer
somebody you confirm that they know
where you are
so yeah you got to be careful about that
careful
do you um get requests i sometimes get
requests in the mail
that are strange strange requests
yeah well you know just so ordinary come
to my wedding you know
i'm in arizona you know
[Music]
uh do this do that but uh
do you ever get requests for money sure
absolutely because i sent you one
i asked you for 800 i never heard back
well you did get it because otherwise
it was money misspent
[Laughter]
i sent it to you immediately
okay well then i just must have
misplaced it i occasionally
think of you know i should write
christopher walken and see if i could
get some money and just to see what
happens
and uh i put the cash in the envelope so
maybe somebody took it
let's talk about wild mountain time it's
a beautiful movie it's gorgeous
and um shot in such a beautiful location
and in this film uh you were required to
have an irish accent
which is can can be tricky it is
and and i studied you know before i went
there i had recordings and
things to help me but when i got there
everybody was irish
so that was intimidating and i had to
get used to that
and but it i hadn't been to ireland for
some reason there are places
i've i've never been and never been to
ireland
no and it was really uh beautiful
it was in a place uh
some hours outside of dublin in the
country and uh
there really were rainbows and it was
green and it was moody
and uh uh
it was just beautiful the place we
stayed in uh had a rookery
where they raised hawks and falcons and
owls and
uh it was uh it was a
magical experience yeah it's something
yeah
you know wonderful actors oh yeah i mean
uh the the cast is you have a you have a
fantastic cast
john patrick shanley emily blunt jamie
dornan
john hamm development
yeah just and and i don't know if you
noticed it the
the irish accent i mean obviously there
are so many different kinds of irish
accent but it's very musical
to me that's when i come from 100
irish um and when i've gone back to
ireland i've always been transfixed by
the musicality of the way they talk
it almost sounds like they're singing
when they talk you know yes
well that whole part of the world there
is that that
thing with language uh ireland wales
scotland you know
sure but i hadn't been to ireland and i
i want to go back yeah well
soon i'm hoping we'll all be able to
travel you know that'd be nice
you know you've been you've been inside
now for as long as probably the rest of
us
just stuck inside the last time i was
the new york
uh city was uh you know eight nine
months ago
yeah march yeah um well we have a clip
here
and and this is a clip and you can tell
just even in this clip
uh and this is the scene with you and
and emily blunt just how
gorgeous the location is i mean lots of
it it seems like a lot of animals farm
country was this anything that you grew
up with at all
in your experience no i was born in new
york city and
um this is really different yeah
yeah now you don't encounter a lot of
sort of draft horses
in new york cows cows
and cows wearing cow bells
yes and cows cows are misunderstood
they're
actually quite aggressive oh really
yeah maybe just with you maybe
maybe but they'd get a look in their eye
and then go for you you know
that's just you that's nobody else
nobody else has ever said that about a
cow that's them
realizing who you are and wanting to you
know wanting to get in on that you know
that's all
that's all that is just it's turf
[Laughter]
you're not having turf wars with cows
well here's a clip we're going to show
now uh from uh
wild mountain time where you're talking
to your daughter who's played by emily
blunt
let's take a look are you in love with
anthony it's more than love
don't play now go while your damn gates
are open no i'm not i'm not done with
you
it's not normal i don't care you'll
never marry well then neither will i
and he will be in his house and i'll be
in mine rosemary
be quick i need to pee and you'd sell to
a yank would you he's o'reilly he's a
yank
your trespasser now drop this plush or
i'll kill you
would you have the place called an
auction anthony will
never marry or he will wake up look to
yourself
no if it comes to that i'll freeze my
eggs
what i freeze my eggs if he's slow
i'll wait you should freeze your whole
body if you're waiting for that
i believe he will come to me i need to
settle
wild mountain time is available in
theaters and
on demand you must have shot this just
before covid
yes uh in october of last year wow
doesn't that seem like a million years
ago it certainly does
well this has been uh as always an honor
and a privilege to talk to you
really you're uh you're you're one of my
favorite actors of all
time and uh just a joy to get to talk to
and i'm glad you're doing well
and you're staying safe thank you conan
it's a pleasure and i'm glad to see you
so well
yeah well i have a lot of makeup on so
you
you actually have no idea how this is a
great
this is a great day they're starting
with the vaccines isn't that great yeah
the vaccines are beginning
it's a wonderful today it's the
beginning of something
it's the beginning of the end i think
let's hope
well the beginning of the end of the
badness not the beginning of the end of
the
forget it either way it's a good thing i
should have let you say it and not me
christopher walken thank you very much
thank you really it's been an honor
thank you